[Music]
Sonic returns filming is officially
scheduled to begin this September on
part three of the popular video game
adaptation regardless of the actor
strike the solution to the problem is
surprisingly simple it's understandable
that they didn't want to wait any longer
to produce Sonic 3. for Paramount
Pictures the previous movie adaptations
of the iconic Hedgehog proved to be
extremely successful Sonic 1 and Sonic 2
collectively grossed over 700 million
dollars worldwide it was therefore
unsurprising that in addition to the
planned spin-off series Knuckles a third
part of the film series was also
announced however when the actor strike
came into effect on July 14 2023 all
movie and TV Productions were put on
hold for an unknown period of time
including Sonic 3. nevertheless screen
Daily Now reports that they have
apparently found a way to carry out the
filming despite the ongoing strike it
was announced that the production team
for Sonic 3 will start shooting in
September of this year without the
actor's involvement the filming location
in London proves to be extremely
beneficial for the production as there
are no picketing guidelines in the UK
that could prevent a production from
taking place without the actors Sonic
and his companions are CGI characters
anyway and the new Shadow the Hedgehog
character also originates from the
computer so it should be an easy task to
devote some of the production to them
first the actor scenes would then be
added after the strike is over however
it is already suspected that they will
play a rather minor role in the third
part anyway fans are likely to be
relieved that the planned release date
of December 20th 2024 remains unchanged
for the strikers on the other hand this
news puts a damper on the situation
because any production that continues
despite the strike is likely to
considerably reduce the pressure on the
opposing side still the full production
of Sonic the Hedgehog 3 can only be
concluded after the strike is over in
the end things can't be done without the
actors
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you